hello veteran Call of Duty players and
welcome new players Modern Warfare is a
Sandbox and that means there's a lot of
silly fun and tactically interesting
things you can learn to do some of it
pretty unexpected
the Modern Warfare 2 Beta is no
different so let's get started with 18
things you didn't know about Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 2 Beta Edition
number one you played Warzone already
congratulations how was it Modern
Warfare 2019 did this clever thing where
warzone's first map for dance was just
made up of all the other maps that
players have been grinding away on since
launch and Modern Warfare 2 looks to be
no different the serif Bay map that you
played on in the beta oh hello there
serif Bay on the war zone map including
this Observatory I mean you didn't
really play Warzone so much as you know
in the space but you did mess around
with one of Warzone 2.0's new ideas
called strongholds which are areas full
of bots and high tiered loot Modern
Warfare 2019's Warzone also had a
limited time big Team Battle modes so
maybe the circle didn't close but you
you've sort of done it and as an update
to this video they've now confirmed it
in a blog post that you were testing the
war zone map number two attention to
detail baby the Modern Warfare series is
known for some great animations and
attention to detail even though some
parts of the beta were technically rough
like streaming textures not loading well
on my PS4 Pro a lot of the core goodness
was there for example if you inspect
your weapon they have different
animations depending on what kind of
bullets you loaded for example regular
versus hollow point bullets appear
different or if you inspect your weapon
with one bullet left the magazine is
dried but there's one in the chamber
some of these were broken in the beta
but we'll give it to them they've got
some time to fix it three getting stabby
more than just gun animation switch
depending on what you have in your
Loadout if you melee normally you use
your rifle butt but if you have a
throwing knife equipped you'll use that
instead while we're here the game also
seems to have different execution
animations depending on if they're
standing or on the ground self Reviving
number four so much around Vehicles I'm
a battlefield guy so this one really
gets me going you can attach so many
things to them some of which were in
Modern Warfare 2019 and the first war
zone for starters you can attach the
trophy system which will stop incoming
rockets and projectiles it's a little
different in Modern Warfare 2 it
vanishes after a set time unlike how it
would just hang around until it was used
up in Warzone this could be a balance
change you can also stick cameras to
your vehicle for a cinematic view
landmines can go on the hood not really
sure what that does and other field
upgrades throwables and tacticals can be
attached to varying degrees of effect
you can jeep stuff like in Battlefield
it seems to detonate right after you
jump out so you kind of have to time it
right number five hang on walls aren't
the only thing you can hang out on peek
over and shoot from if you have a pistol
equipped in the beta you can straight up
hang off the sides of vehicles and do
your best Mirror's Edge impression this
could come in clutch later on when
Warzone 2.0 launches letting you get on
top of vehicles quickly or roll with a
full Squad plus several more people on
the outside number six hop on you might
be used to Jumping onto the back of an
enemy cargo truck in Warzone and
dispatching the driver you can do it
again here jump onto moving vehicles and
shoot down through the turret to get the
people inside number seven want to play
a little shell game if you're under Fire
while inside a vehicle rapidly switch
seats to get out of the way while you're
there you can either shoot out from the
inside or now lean out to fire or deploy
gadgets enemies won't know what you're
about to do but between the two options
people really don't expect you to stay
inside and simply shoot out if your
vehicle has some armor left it's much
faster than having to hop out get
reoriented and then Engage The Enemy you
can also shoot straight through the
glass of the vehicle you're in or
through glass of broken down vehicles
around the map number eight gadgets have
other uses a lot of the gadgets in
Modern Warfare 2 have planned in
unplanned secondary uses and the game
keeps its attention to detail here as
well release at proximity mine
underwater and it flows to the surface
to wait for boats but throw a drill
charge or thermite and it Fizzles out
and sinks smoke will also flow to the
surface before making clouds the
inflatable decoy will hilariously take
the pose of a swimmer you can also float
spawn flares here make sure to do it
under dock so people don't notice where
you put them Deployable barricades in
Modern Warfare 2019 could be used to
climb to places you couldn't reach
normally and that seems to have been
removed in this game but you can still
use a Loadout drop to do the same thing
this is important because you can't seem
to open doors to climb up to higher
places also like you could in 2019. I'm
still testing to see if you can launch
things with the dummy and so far I've
gotten it to slightly lit vehicles and
also murk me but I honestly can't wait
for the video when someone walks into a
room and like 20 of these things go off
number nine Jerome bomber by equipping
C4 in the field upgrade Recon drone you
can send a deadly little package of love
to whatever sniper is bothering you
hello Battlefield currently you can only
attach one C4 per run but it totally
works
number 10 frisbee golf you can hook
proximity mines like a frisbee all you
got to do is Sprint or jump right before
throwing them this lets you Chuck them
over walls number 11. learn the routes
this is an Infinity Ward Call of Duty
game so that means plenty of unexpected
places to climb and interesting ways to
reach areas you might not think make
sure to explore the map to find places
you can get to in clever ways or look
for great Vantage points like inside
this sign on serif Bay number 12 master
your inner dolphin if you time it right
you can dolphin dive straight through
glass windows into buildings off eye
rooftops into water or over Low cover
it's a great way to surprise people
[Music]
number 13 side shoot if you want to
parachute a greater distance in Modern
Warfare 2019 what you do is you leap
going to third person and drift sideways
after a few tests in Modern Warfare 2 it
seems like it still works it might not
be quite as effective as before but I
recommend trying it number 14 first
downgrades maybe this is still just a
beta so take this section with the idea
that things might change or are supposed
to change from a beta before launch
despite in preview events Vehicles being
described as having multiple parts that
could be damaged and blown off like
doors windows Etc bumpers and then
repaired back after going back through
my footage I realized I did see these
things as I was playing but they just
weren't that impressive or impactful
there's probably a distinction to make
here between Vehicles you can drive and
those just scatter around the maps but
even those just scattered around they
were less destructible on Battle maps
than core maps we shot out tires broke
Windows took off mirrors and encountered
some strange floating mechanics that
just didn't quite line up with the
complex damage models that were
described in preview events we'll just
have to see if it winds up being a Down
grade or something only in Warzone 2.0
but that runs on the same engine so it's
hard to say there were some other early
features that might have been cut from
the game like the ability to fine-tune
attachments number 15 working as
intended maybe if vehicles are coming at
you you're supposed to be able to make
them go Haywire with a shock stick or
shut them down with DDOS it's hard to
tell if this is working as intended
because in the beta Vehicles just seem
to carry on as if they didn't register
the hit or maybe their momentum just
carried them forward and the effect
ended so quickly that it was barely
noticeable summer who covers Call of
Duty and our team notice shock sticks
did temporarily stall apcs but didn't
even phase tanks still don't be that
person who throws the shock stick inside
the car like me which I did totally on
purpose to make things a little bit
trickier with balance seemed like
proximity mines and shoulder-fired
Rockets all seem to need two or more
solid hits to take down even lighter
armored trucks number 16 drill baby
drill you've probably hit plenty of
cover with drill charges but it works on
floors and ceilings also if you see
someone on radar who's not on your level
there's a little arrow on the radar that
shows if they're above or below you go
ahead and toss the drill charge on the
floor or ceiling it is so satisfying
drill charges will also force all
occupants out of vehicles or they will
explode inside in addition drill charges
surprisingly work on competitive modes
like Search and Destroy which in the
past have had impenetrable objectives
very Rainbow Six Siege of them
number 17 kill streaks kill kill streaks
if that pesky vital jet is giving you a
hard time and you have your kill streak
turned you can take care of it in Modern
Warfare 2019 both cruise missiles and
cluster strikes can blow up VTOL jets
with players even demonstrating that
cruise missiles could take down an
AC-130 if you were fast enough we're
still testing this out in the beta but
at minimum we've already demolished a
veto with an AC-130 and a mortar strike
while we're here if you've ever heard
the dreaded missile incoming warning if
you have a trophy system toss that down
and it will stop that kill streak
number 18 the eye of Sauron there's a
lot of smoke that happens from
explosions on the battlefield and you
can harness the power of that literal
fog of War by packing a thermal scope
the hybrid sites didn't seem to work but
dedicated thermal optics can see right
through that smoke including smoke you
intentionally put in front of you with a
smoke grenade it's dirty but it works as
we get into the main game we'll look for
some counters like how hot flares and
thermite might make it hard to see man
this game has a fun sandbox veteran
players tell us what we missed in the
comments below I hope you enjoyed the
beta because we're diving deeper as we
get into the multi-week launch of
campaign multiplayer spec ops Warzone
2.0 with DMZ and whatever raids wind up
being let's go thanks for watching
all right